PROBLEM FOR THE MID
AIR TO GET IT FROM THE NET.
SAVED MAROONS.
WHO SCORED THE RANGERS GOA PANA.
IN.
DEFLECTED OUT OF AROUND.
LAFRENIERE.
TAKE
KAAPOPASS.
KAAPO KAKKO WASTED NO TIME, KNEW
THE GOALTENDER WAS OUT. AGAIN.
LEHKONEN.
WIDE OPEN NET, CHECKED IT THE N.
LEHKONEN W CAME AROUND THE NET.
DVORAK, LIFTEDSHESTERKIN WAS LOR
WAY, WAS A SPLIT SECOND LATE
GETTTT
ZIBANEJAD TO GOING THE OTHER WA.
LEFT SIDE OFUCK.
RANGERS HAVE GOODROW AND ROONEY.
>> BY FAR, BEST IN THE PASS KEE.
IT IS STILL A PANARIN, FINDS
RANGERS SCHEDULED TO
CHANGE.
THAT'S WHY TOFFOLI WAS WIDE RAN
MONTREAL.
AND RIGHT BACK TO THE NEUTRAL
ZONE.
THEY HAD TO BACK NET.
CHYTIL.
OH!
CR TO THE NET.
SAVE.
TWO SAVES
POSITION.
LOOK ATFOX.
LEHKONEN BEHIND THE NET.
PASS IN SHESTERKIN.
WHAT A SHOT BY SHESTERKIN.
HERE'S GALLAGHER WITH THE PASS